kyra i love seeing you we're all
separated during covid and then today
i'm driving to work
and i'm like i get my kira time so thank
you
oh my gosh that's so nice yeah it's been
such a long time that i'm so happy to
see you even under these circumstances
yeah i know this is nice where are you
right now that's a beautiful
it looks like i'm talking to you and
you're in an art museum
i know it's crazy i'm really lucky girl
i live in
in uh i have a place in los angeles
beautiful okay yeah
this is this is my place in los angeles
and yeah i mean i get to see the green i
mean jesus
it's nice it's really nice and and you i
mean all of us
we're all going through the same thing
we're at home or
i get my big thing every day is i get to
come to this abandoned theater
and and and do the show but other than
that i'm at home
and feeling kind of trapped i understand
you got out
you actually went out for an evening of
fun how do you do that right now
i did well i got invited to go to this
comedy show
at magic castle and so i went to magic
castle
and it's out it's outdoors right
outdoors but you're in your car
six feet apart and you tune into a radio
station and i thought this is horrible
this is going to be terrible but then
people came out and they were so funny
and they were so amazing and sherry
sheppard was there and also one of your
writers
oh rory lori kilmartin yeah lori
kilmartin
who killed it yes who was absolutely
fantastic
and you know among all the other things
that are incredibly weird about it you
know these poor
first of all it can't have been easy for
these guys i mean it's got to be so
weird
you're like literally looking out on a
sea of cars you can't really hear people
right but give you these plastic
clackers that are just like this
you know horrible like plastic nightmare
that like you're gonna throw out right
after you use it right
but you know and it makes a clapping
sound so that the clapping sound in fact
you're funny today you're funny tonight
i mean because it's night
thank you yeah sure the sun coming in
exactly
that sounds weird no it's good believe
me i can imagine that if i were one of
the comedians up there
this is what i would want to hear it's
awful but you know what
it's better than nothing and of course
i'm so
codependent i'm like ah my arm's like
killing me by the end of it but you know
that's hard to do